[Music]  it is a grave mistake  to think too much  patrick sumner i'm the new surgeon  welcome aboard  we have an intellectual on board i  wonder how we cope with those rough  brutes to the sea  where did you become a surgeon because i  wish to advance  from my humble origins yet here you are  the  whaler i wonder what has happened to  those ambitions  [Music]  no man has ever caught a whale this far  north before  some men are closer to the darkness  to the primitive they are gradually  freezing day by day  why do you care so much i believe a good  man is in need of ethics  if you've them of them we are no more  than beasts  [Music]  void wager that's the least of our  problems  the very least i'd say  only devil here is the one inside  ourselves  perhaps life cannot be puzzled but  should we survive  in whatever fashion a man can manage  [Music]  you